i'm opening up cobra kai so we can fight
back no i'm not opening up a cobra kai
am i that would change the whole show a
vodka and egg smoothie an intimate
moment and a rat roaming around the set
of cobra kai what else did we miss in
deleted scenes and blooper moments in
this video we'll be checking out 15 of
the best deleted scenes and bloopers
from the series number one in cobra kai
you gotta learn to stick those landings
it's easier said than done though
practice is necessary even four seasons
in all right
while they don't always nail it this
team never fails to try try again
number two it's the beginning of a new
era the eagle fangs and the miyagidos
putting their differences aside to train
and work in the same dojo was a special
start to the fourth season and there was
even more great footage captured than
what we actually saw in the show it's a
lot of work to put into these scenes
that end up on the cutting room floor
but hey it makes great bonus material
for us to watch there was no shortage of
training on and off screen this team
went to work number three we've got
tense talks before breakfast is even
finished season three filmed this scene
but it didn't make the series daniel's
care for robbie came through in this
deleted take as he worried about his
whereabouts and with good reason we also
get a moment to recognize just how left
out anthony could be easily dismissed by
his family and unable to connect more
you know if i got suspended for starting
a karate war
something tells me you guys wouldn't be
this nice to me but maybe his guess that
robbie was up to something illegal was a
little too on the nose to include this
time around or they get caught doing
something illegal to stay afloat it may
not have been released with the season
but we're glad this special one did get
seen yeah
definitely number four if you've got a
weak stomach you'll be glad this scene
got cut after larusso and johnny decided
to work together johnny introduced his
workout smoothie and uh well
larusso probably could have done without
we love a berry blend or a power green
smoothie but this was more of a
vodka and eggs vibe which larusso had to
drink while blindfolded no less this
could only be described as baby food in
real life by exec producer josh heald
but we doubt any babies would have been
into this combo which was actually a
blend of random ingredients the prop
master got together no surprise that it
took like an interminable amount of time
for him to choke down whatever the heck
the prop master made how in the world
did he get through filming i kept
thinking of stallone in the original
rocky film taking the five eggs down but
i went for it too bad the actor went
through all that just for the scene to
be cut completely number five shall we
dance yes yes yes okay romance much the
setting the music the acting kumuko's
moving words sharing just how deeply
she's been affected by daniel in her
life has us gushing and shipping these
two oh so hard she literally told him
you saved my life
it's a beautiful scene but ultimately
including it could have felt like a bit
of a jab for amanda but the chemistry
and connection between these two is
undeniable and full of respect so we can
still appreciate their having a final
intimate moment before their farewell
they have both saved each other in some
way after all number six it's time to
get to work and it's definitely not all
about the gram this scene had sam coming
in ready to fight while the boys worried
about their instagame we always knew sam
had that fiery spirit in her but not
including this feisty moment in the
third season did give a starker contrast
to her boss attitude in season four that
being said she's definitely shown off
some better moves in the series who can
really blame sam for wanting the rest of
the miyagidos to be as committed as she
was number seven will he show won't he
show this little blooper seemed to catch
most of the crew off guard and had them
giggling in fits how is things going
what happened to your eye it starts with
robbie deep and serious with mood music
and all and then well there's the
off-the-cuff cursing and casual banter
the word i told you at the church thank
you
at least they weren't too intensely
affected filming more emotional scenes
like this one number eight they're going
head to head miyagi does versus the
eagle fangs a tale as old as time if
anyone needed proof of just how tough
sam is here it is increase the strategy
of the eagle fangs playing it cool and
provoking the miyagi does was clearly a
work in this case the scene would have
given us some context for the arcade
fight and we always loved to see this
side of sam but saving the action
ultimately made more sense in the show's
structure
and we'll be ready number nine ready
listen there's some good advice waiting
why do you think your father lost to
larusso chris teaches robbie about more
than just how to fight in this one the
interaction between the pair gives us a
new side of the usually villainous
crease and honestly what he tells robbie
about being focused rings very true
remember
there's one part of your body that you
must always protect
right here
no one can deny he's a good teacher keep
your mind clear focused and balanced
well that's advice we take any day
number 10 what's back there rat sets are
hectic enough as it is the last thing
the cobra kai team needed was an
unwelcome visitor sorry a rat just ran
back there
i want to go home caution everyone there
are rodents on set or is it just
pranksters
[Music]
kubra kai is never dull and on set well
you can be sure there wasn't a dull
moment number 11 a blooper reel isn't
complete without showing off some dance
moves the cobra kai's team dance styles
were varied from the watusi vibes to the
subtle hips don't lie to the classic
moves
sure they weren't always enthusiastic
but they never let the groove die and
you know whatever this is oh and don't
forget to floss
what's so funny miss robinson
it's a snake dew
number 12 if you know you know it just
wouldn't be the cobra kai set without
this good stuff this is a snake do you
don't want to mess with this
but what is it exactly a little teasing
snake if we were working with this crew
we'd do it as much as we could ourselves
i don't get a chance to do it as much as
i'd like number 13 she gets knocked down
but she gets up again
and again and again and again
rollerblading is tricky to pull off so
kudos to her for keeping at it even
though she wound up with some bruises
afterwards
okay one more time sorry her karate
skills are much stronger than her
rollerblading number fourteen on mondays
we take a tumble
it's a monday cobra kai wasn't short on
action on screen but getting those shots
took a number of tries
and a lot of instances that needed to be
bleeped
they got twisted up in the work and
themselves but you can be sure they
finish the day hugging it out
and they do know how to look on the
bright side
it tastes good well the actors didn't
always nail it they were always ready to
go even after that meant being a bit too
ready
i started too early number 15 everybody
and everything please quiet onset
we hear that
technology is great but it can get in
the way of tv making magic all right
he's a better man than you would ever be
that's a nice phone i like it
that's okay sorry i'm having trouble
with it
and then you know all the other general
nuisances that can come up in life try
another one without the
aircraft carrier filming outdoors is a
whole other mess of struggles to get
through
i've paused for bees twice it's still by
your leg okay so who else is wondering
just how much other footage there is
that round up on the cutting room floor
these bloopers and deleted scenes show
just how deep the story goes and make us
love the series even more which deleted
scene do you think should have made the
final cut